♪ >> FORMER PRESIDENT OBAMA IS
BACK AND HITTING THE CAMPAIGN
TRAIL TO HELP DEMOCRATS RAKE IN
THE CASH BEFORE THE MIDTERMS.
IT COMES JUST A DAY AFTER OBAMA
MADE HIS HEROIC RETURN TO THE
WHITE HOUSE TO UNVEIL HIS
OFFICIAL WHITE HOUSE PORTRAIT.
THE LIBERAL MEDIA GUSHING LIKE
LITTLE SCHOOL CHILDREN.
>> AS THE NATION'S FIRST AND
ONLY BLACK PRESIDENT AND FIRST
LADY, THE OBAMAS SAID THOSE WILL
TELL A STORY AND REMINDER THAT
EVERYONE HAS A PLACE IN THIS
COUNTRY, DAVID.
>> POWERFUL DAY.
>> OBSTRUCTING CERUMEN THE
SCREEN, IT WAS A WARM EVENT --
ON THE SCREEN, IT WAS A WARM
SEVENTH EVENT AND NOSTALGIA AND
IT WAS PACKED AND I HAVEN'T SEEN
IT THAT PACKED IN A LONG TIME.
>> FORMER PRESIDENT TRUMP DID
NOT INVITE OBAMA.
THIS MOMENT PARTICULARLY
POIGNANT FOR THE FIRST BLACK
PRESIDENT AND FIRST LADY.
>> CAN WE SEE THAT PORTRAIT OF
FORMER PRESIDENT OBAMA AND I
FIND THIS STRIKING.
CAN WE SEE IT THERE.
WHAT'S MISSING?
HIS BACKGROUND.
WE'LL BE RIGHT BACK.
I THINK WE CAN SEND -- WE SHOULD
END THIS SEGMENT RIGHT NOW.
I NEED TO GO TO THE BATHROOM.
>> LIKE WIPE MY SKYPE ROOM
GIVING HIM A ZERO.
THAT WAS A TERRIBLE JOKE.
>> I LOVE IT, THE DELAYED
HORROR.
>> I GET IT, IT COULD HAVE BEEN
SOMETHING SASSIER.
>> IT'S NEVER THAT EASY WITH
GREG.
>> HE'S KENYAN, WHATEVER.
>> YEP.
>> YOU DIDN'T SAY IT.
>> NO, HE MADE ME SAY IT.
JUST WHATEVER.
REQUISITE, LIBERAL, FAN GIRLING.
I WAS REALLY SO PLEASED TO SEE
THEM BACK IN THE WHITE HOUSE
YESTERDAY.
IT WAS -- WHAT?
YOU CAN LAUGH ABOUT IT.
HE MEANS A LOT TO THE PARTY.
THE PORTRAITS WERE GORGEOUS AND
THEY WERE FUNNY AND SWEET AND
MICHELLE WAS THE ONE CONVEYING
THE HEAVIER MESSAGE IN ALL OF IT
ABOUT THE THREATS WE'RE FACING
TODAY AND YOU COULD HAVE PUT ME
IN THE MONTAGE.
>> LOOKS LIKE THEY'RE YOUR
ROYALTY.
>> YOU'D LIKE KING OBAMA.
>> ISN'T THAT WHAT HE ALREADY
WAS?
>> YEAH, MAYBE WHERE HE WAS
FROM.
WE'LL BE RIGHT BACK.
JUDGE, I THINK HE'S GOING TO
SPEAK ABOUT -- ISN'T HE ALSO
GOING TO TALK ABOUT EXTREME MAGA
REPUBLICANS?
IS IT WISE TO PILE IN ON THIS --
>> THINK THINK IT'S A WINNING
MESSAGE AND THEY'VE GOT TO DO
SOMETHING BECAUSE THEY CAN'T
TALK ABOUT WHAT THEY DID.
WHEN I WAS LISTENING TO THE
REPORTERS, IT WAS A POWERFUL DAY
AND BIGGEST CELEBRATION WE'VE
SEEN IN THE EAST ROOM.
IT WAS EXCITING.
WHAT WAS SO POWERFUL?
THEY HAD A PAINTING.
I GET IT.
THEY'RE HAPPY TO SEE THEM.
I'M HAPPY TO SEE A PRESIDENT
THAT CAN COMPLETE A SENTENCE.
REALLY, I WAS HAPPY TO SEE HIM
BACK TOO.
>> YEAH, THAT'S TRUE.
JESSE, DO YOU -- THERE'S TWO
CAMPS HERE.
IS THERE A BROMAN CE BETWEEN O
AND JOE OR A FEUD?
DOES JOE REMEMBER HIM?
>> THAT'S A GOOD QUESTION.
>> I FIND IT WEIRD TO TALK ABOUT
GUY'S RELATIONSHIPS.
THERE'S NO BROMAN CE, THEY JUST
WORK TOGETHER.
>> THAT'S LIKE YOU AND ME.
>> ACTUALLY, THAT'S A BROMANCE.
BUSH, CHEYNEY, PENCE, TRUMP.
NO BROMANCE BUT THE DEMOCRATS
ALWAYS ROMANTICIZE THINGS.
IT'S LIKE THEY HAVE LUNCH DATES
AND MAKE FRIENDSHIP BRACELETS.
WOMEN ALWAYS DO IT.
GO OUT FOR DRINKS WITH YOUR ARE
FRIEND, GREG, GUY FRIEND, AND
COME BACK AND YOUR LIFE WILL BE
LIKE, WHAT DO YOU GUYS TALK
ABOUT?
I DON'T KNOW.
HOW IS HE?
HE'S FINE, I GUESS.
WHAT YOU'D GUYS DO?
WE WATCHED THE GAME.
ISN'T THAT CUTE.
>> YOU BROUGHT THIS BACK TO THE
A BLOCK WHO WAS TALKING ABOUT
ROYALTY AND WHO WASN'T.
>> YEAH.
>> WE WERE LIKE SITTING HERE
GOING LIKE WHAT DO WE SAY?
YOU GUYS WERE LIKE, ALL IN.
IT WAS LIKE YOU COULD HAVE
TALKED -- WE COULD HAVE DONE
THREE HOURS ON IT.
>> WE DID OUR ASSIGNMENT.
>> YES.
>> THAT'S TRUE, YOU DID DO YOUR
ASSIGNMENT.
WE SHOULD BLAME MEGAN, OUR
PRODUCER.
>> YEAH, BLAME HER FOR SURE.
>> DO YOU THINK -- DO YOU THINK
HE HELPS THE DEMOCRATS GET OUT
TO VOTE?
>> I WAS ASTONISHED BY THE OBAMA
NEWS.
I THOUGHT THAT EVERYTHING WAS
TURNING AROUND FOR THE DEMOCRATS
AND THOUGHT EVERYTHING WAS
GREAT.
I THOUGHT THEY'RE PASSING ALL
THOSE LEGISLATION AND GAS PRICES
ARE TICKING DOWN AND INFLATION
IS TICKING DOWN.
WHY DO THEY NEED OBAMA?
ARGUABLY YOU COULD SAY IF YOU'RE
THE BIDEN TEAM, THEY'VE HAD MANY
MORE LEGISLATIVE ACCOMPLISHMENTS
THAN OBAMA DID AND HE HAD 60
SENATORS.
BELIEVE ME, IN THE FEUD, THOSE
PLAYING OUT BEHIND THE SCENES IF
YOU SEE THE PRIVATE TEXT
MESSAGES, THE BIDEN PEOPLE WERE
PICKING UP ON THAT AND LORDING
IT OVER THE OBAMA PEOPLE
QUIETLY.
>> OH, INTEREST.
>> SPICEY.
>> UH-HUH.
>> MAYBE NOT.
I DON'T KN